this is been a show that's been more
than a decade of your life yeah how are
you preparing for the ending and what
are you looking to tackle next
um it's so preparing for the ending is
I'm not really preparing for it at all
I'm just waiting for it to like hit me
like a freight train and for what's next
I've got something coming out of
Christmas and and we'll just lots
there's lots of exciting things I've
started a charity called same you same
you dog and I've started a production
company and so I'm it's going to be a
really exciting next chapter and I don't
know I don't know I'm so excited to hear
about the charity that you started and
we were so touched to hear about your
story and see that we really opened up
about your health conditions why was it
important for you to share your story
because I just want to help people I
want to make them feel not alone because
they're not the only ones who have
experienced something like that and and
I and I know felt like I had an
opportunity to do that so it seemed like
the only thing to do in your opinion as
we go into season a who do you think it
deserves the Iron Throne I mean I do
damn it Daenerys yeah whatever all the
other people who deserve it more but no
I'm gonna say the mother of dragons
should get the throne
lastly we have a question train going on
right now and your question comes from
sophie turner well yeah and she wants to
know which character's story line yes
has been your least favorite my least
favorite oh that's so oh and my least
favorite story line I mean I kind of
oh my goodness there were like bits
there were bits of a varus's storyline
that I just because I just want Varys to
like just turn around and like you know
kill someone to their face or lay just
tell everyone every day you're better
and so you just always feel like you're
on the way you're on the edge of your
seat waiting for him to kind of blow up
and that's that's it now you leave a
question for the next game of Thrones
cast member okay the next game of
Thrones class member is what was your
most memorable onset meal why not
[Music]
[Applause]